giants all-star starter mike the
right-hander kevin gausman kevin gossman
who is uh 30 years of age and he's in
his eighth year at the big league level
and 17 starts this year he's been
stellar just a model of consistency 124
strikeouts and 27 walks 108 innings
that's dominant just underway first
inning turner strikes out swinging that
is a great split
here's the one-two pitch swing and a
miss he struck him out with a splitter
he threw a great splitter to strike out
josh bell
but he has a sinker cutter curveball
changeup mix majority sinkers to
righties and then he'll throw that
sinker and cutter to left-handed hitters
that one is lined to right field and
it's going to get down for a hit
wade will hustle his way to third base
soto
will keep yastremski at first first and
third nobody out for the giants
nats will take a double play shot and
concede a run if they get a grounder at
somebody
instead it's a pop-up
betty was there under it and then
escobar clears everybody out so one away
in the bottom of the first inning
and a ball ripped and there's another
way to turn a double play
as juski can't get back and the inning
is over just like that a line drive
double play
gets fetty out of the inning
that ball ripped
shortstop crawford
safe is the call
wade did everything he could to stay on
the bag
and a tremendous effort by brandon
crawford to at least make it close 0-2
got him swinging foul tip right into the
mid of casalli
strikeout number three for gaussman the
one-two offering swing gonna miss he
struck it out with a high fastball
he's got the really good fastball going
today that was 97 miles an hour
here's a guy who could hit one into the
cove brandon crawford instead will just
line the first pitch into right center
field for a lead off hit as you used to
say in old rock and roll radio when i
was a kid and the hits just keep on
coming
yeah that's a strikeout entire baseball
and then some in the box and for eric
fetty strikeout number one
duggar hits one hard on one hop and it
kicks right over escobar into shallow
right field crawford never hesitated and
he'll go around to third
that's a hit for stephen duggar
now here is casalli for the second
inning in a row the giants have runners
at first and third they had first and
third nobody out in the first inning
casalli to deep center field victor
robles going back all the way back
kurt casale man what a hot streak his
fourth home run of the year
420 to center field
to make it three-nothing giants
[Applause]
strike call strike three call
lamont wade took and he walked his first
time but eric fetty pinpointed that one
that's neat somebody to be a hammer the
eighth place hitter and bunts third base
side wilmer tough play barehand throws
to first got him
nicely done so you want to be a big
league third baseman huh all right well
the deal is you have to be able to make
this play
wilmer has worked so hard to get better
over there and it's paid off
0-2 pitch swinging him as he struck him
out
on
a slider that time fifth strikeout for
kevin gausman
three and two pitch
anthony's strike three called a 96 mile
an hour fastball
six strikeouts in three innings three
nothing giants bases loaded two down
guardsmen five hits 29 at bats for the
year got to walk his first time the one
two swinging a miss got him on a change
up down and outside so fetty does work
out of trouble in the third
ready to go against turner struck out
swinging back in the first inning
strikes recall
seventh strikeout for guardsmen so the
nationals have a chance here and here's
starlin castro who extended his hitting
streak with the infield hit in the
second end and then was picked off
here's the pitch castro ground ball to
short to his right crawford has it to
second one solano the first
got him double play
nicely turned by the giants middle
infield crawford to solano to wade
gausman gets the ground ball couple of
hits no runs gausman pitches through it
middle of the fourth josh harrison for
the nationals inning number five here's
his pitch harrison strikes out swinging
that splitter was up but it worked eight
strikeouts for gaussman now
one or
two and another strikeout number nine
in four and two third innings for
guardsmen cannot throw a split any
better than that
it's impossible
swinging a broken bat roller toward
third coming into field flores he's got
it throws to first
in time to get robless for out number
three another strong inning for crosman
kevin gausman against the 9-1-2 spots
here
here's a swing a fly ball left center
field dickerson over alex dickerson will
reach up and make the catch so escobar
is retired two down
three nothing giants two out spaces
empty for turner 2-2
turner bounces it to the left side over
to his left grabbing it flora spins
around throws to first he got him what a
play
wilmer flores throws out one of the
fastest players in the big leagues on a
tough play he gets trey turner sally to
second with one out and brings up lamont
wade jr here's the one two
swinging it's poked in the air third
base side battling the sun is castro
he'll make the catch in fair territory
on the dirt for the second out
the one two a little looper into shallow
left could fall harrison comes in
reaches down and makes a shoestring
catch
caught that one basically in the heel of
the glove kevin gausman has been stellar
through six solid innings and so the
nationals have drawn back-to-back walks
on a pitch up basement left field
juan soto
held it third by bob henley bases are
loaded with nobody out gabe kepler's
coming out dominic leone is going to
inherit a tight spot here
and the fans
with a standing ovation for kevin
gausman
sets kicks throws swinging a ground ball
up the middle could be two crawford to
second for one solano to first low wade
cannot dig it out he drops the ball on
the scoop attempt in the dirt so
harrison is safe
a run will score and it's now three to
one
fires
swing on the best he struck it out
with a slider in the dirt blocked by a
casale who then gets up and tags out
robles closer jake mcgee 18 saves in 20
chances looking for save number 19. the
1-1 harrison the liner right to solano
for round number three
and that's how the giants head into the
all-star break with a win and a
three-game sweep of the washington
nationals
3-1 the final score